in this capture we will see in addition to
details the concept of image contaut
so as we saw near 1
previously an account also makes it a
sudden change in intensity or
the color of adjacent pixels
locally in an image so that's it
corresponds to pixels that was found
in image rights where there are a lot of
variations in intensity or
color of the pixels there by
example all these pixels here here they are
a place where there is enough variation
high intensity between the color of
that wall here and then there the intensity of
pixels for this table here so we got it
we will not tell you that moment
in a horrible act that would make the
account detection in the tale so
would identify the pixels that are on a
account or like that between the wall and the
same thing if you have a shape with
different faces like that here so we
might rather want to have all
the pixels and all the time quoted
associated with this form simply
ability to identify
where are the imitation the different
faces or between different colors
on the form in question so already
Moreover, in this case we can quite
much better identify than this image there
here is a stapler so already
just in the outlines there are a lot
useful information about compared to
the image that so the information that is
reduced by not the original image but
which could allow us to solve
some vision tasks by
computer without difficulty
what can cause outlines
in an image
we distinguish four factors the first
it is when a change of depth
in the picture
so if we look here we have an account
or because that object is there
closer to us in the scene
visual that the background here that can
to be a change of orientation
of a surface then this tale shot here
it exists because we have two facets
face here this phase if they have any
different orientations in space
it can also be a change of
color so related to reflection
finally a surface then we have some
outlines here for example and all along
of character because the character a
different color of the surface on the
cube here and it can be also
illumination changes so a
shadow for example such as we have
here will define an outline in the image
it's the four changes the four
information that we will keep in
doing extraction account we do not live
in a previous example that with the
calculating gradients from an image to
each position
we could do an account detection
another simple by actually taking what
corresponds is the name ucl and
become gradients so
actually if these first elements
of the keeper on the 12th or the inverted little
imported
Well, the norm would be to take the bus
and of the two elements then finally
do the square root for that would be
so the standard ucs lydian gradients
and from this information there we
can do contour detections in
applying to the ground is what we did
here and we had managed quite
well identified the pixels are on the
contours between the landreau there are two
languages ​​is associated with our character
and the background so the outline allowed
to finally identify changes
intensity colors
of reflection finally in my image
and in more complex images or
more natural often the estimate of
variations will be made gross and
actually we saw that the gradient
of an aunt's image of ultimately estimated
the gradient of an image function that
would give the value of the pixels to
any position in an image
and we approximate that by taking a
delta which was equal to a final so to
because of his orders a certain noise
in the estimation of contours then that
may also be due to the fact that some
just noises in the way that the picture has
been gained so let's take an example where
we want to have the estimates of
gradient right on that line there in
this image that drew every year on
an orbit
we have here
the intensity of the pixels on this line
there we will paste a density base
followed by a high intensity and at this
moment are made the estimate of the
vertical variation with a simple
difference in pixels for example this
what we see is that we have a place where
a high variation that corresponds to do
open right where there is a check by
against we had our high value of the
variation that is a bit lower than
the one for the real control but who
still high and just from 6
years is applied it may be
not easy to choose a threshold such as
in this case we're fine
parisseaux of that to face we observe everything
it's not really clear why
would that correspond to open
contours and this point here in fact this
would rather be a fake accounts to people
how can we fix this problem
one way of doing it is actually to
smooth the result of the estimation of
variations as we make the
best vertical versions what we
is that we apply when we
apply a correlation on this filter
water here is what we could do
it's once we'd applied
this correlation there we prepare the continuation
apply a filter that will smooth the
network
and a filter that is often used
to do that it's the one called
the Gaussian filter so see there a
high value in the center then we will see a
little weaker right next
and even more to do a little further
but in this case we chose a
filter with a length of 5
we could have chosen a filter more
serious so also I will add that
when we do the calculation of this smoothing
the beyond in this case we will use
what was called paperless
gold the little gauthier the way we go
the calculation is actually like that it's a
example of file gossip it corresponds to
take for value in the center of
filters the exponential 2-0 in fact and
for others then we will take
the exponential puts distance to
made between this position too and the
meaning so for example if we are at
to be a distance of 1 from the center here a
distance of 200 we will take
the experience y l2 - the distance squared
and we will do that for all
positions in the filter and finally
we will divide by a constant that
that we find everywhere here it is in
does a kind of constants of
standardization so we have to take all
the land numbers we have here equals
add them up so that the filters him
his sleep all the entries in
our filter at all places on
would have a sum that will be equal to 1
we can drink z as a species of
standardization constants we have here in
does the general formula I was saying
that this is an example of filters so
when you have to define the Gaussian movie
we start by choosing what time it is going
have I decided to extend 5
we could also define
two-dimensional throat filters
when this because I was doing a
estimate only on an axis on
the vertical axis I had infiltrating a
only dimension and so we start a
chose the size of the film chooses
also sigma settings that will
determine
as for the smoothing parameters me
determine how well we fit
smooth so let's start plus the value of
six months of strike
the more we go to high school, that is to say that the
calculated value a place in my
estimate your corresponding sons to the
combination of several values ​​everywhere
in the filter so actually if I
take if I do there against correlation
to end up here at a given value
I will actually have after the
correlation 0.56 times the value a
given position in my picture or in
my estimate of variations more
0.21 times the value that just next I
meaning here the 0.21 times the value that
just down then plus 0.02 position
roux 0.02 possible so we see that after
to have made this correlation there in fact
we will have finally replaced the
value a place given by a species
weighted average of the values ​​around
of 1 pixel gives so that's why
we're going to say we're going to him it's actually
because when we see the result
we will get a curve that will be
much smoother and this cinema there
that's what will ultimately control at
how much higher is it the higher the
value here your little one and worth to be
finally close to the values ​​we see
here here so less than the value in the
filter vary according to the distance
between a position and the meaning and the
reason why it's called the
goscinny filter what this formula is
here recent morphine distribution
Gaussian statistics
actually we have the experience of -1
terms of distance squared / term
variation of variant measures
return to our example
when six we apply a smoothing with
a Gaussian filter to our estimate
vertical variations here what we
gets because also for a certain
movie is a curve much more
smooth
because for example the value here in
do it now
a kind of fighting means when
sorry the value here earlier this is a
way of weighting the value that there
had here
but here also here also if
also so instituted and because
that for this place if in fact I had
a fairly high value but close to
very low values ​​the the species of
summit here was flattened in the
variant here and we now have a
higher value only at the place
where we actually had an account at
pedestrians through smoothing
the identification of accounts to become
more robust to noises that could
exist in our previous calculation of
vertical variations so that's a
presentation of a very simple version
detection contaut for example we do
of estimating gradients to make
of estimation of control of the calculation of
image turf generally the crooked
which corresponds to taking the difference
between just a pair of pixels
neighbor little to be improved exist
filters so they'll be a little
more robust in the calculation of
gradients is among other things the filters
of his beautiful who can be viewed
here the contour detection also
rather than doing it with a simple
he has not been improved
among others the Cagnes filter and where
the kenya of the detector that makes a
estimation of the contours detection of
contour improved once one has a
detection of contours son it's
possible to extract information
even higher level for example a
detector of straight lines or
circles in the pictures rather than
to have only one image where at
each fiction also is from a
account or not one could extract from his
the parametric forms finally
straight death is well located this
in an image and it happened with this
what is called the transformation of who
can also be consulted in
Literature